Bringing the people behind our food to life.
The myth of genetic engineering that's been put out in terms of saying this is the solution to hunger...
...is a totally false myth.
Because the only two applications...
...that have been commercialized in these 20 years of genetic engineering.
One is to make seeds make more resilient to herbicides...
...which means you get to spread more Roundup,...
...you get to spread more glyphosate, and you get to spread more poison.
Not a very desirable trait in farming systems...
... especially since what Monsanto will call weeds are actually alternative sources of food.
For example in India, Monsanto had ads...
...selling Roundup with weeds around a woman's hand saying, "Liberate yourself".
But what Monsanto calls weeds is food for the cattle, it's greens for the family,...
...it's medicinal plants.
And the spraying of Roundup is like an ecocide of the planet destroying diversity.